[Musique]
cité sur ce match soit toi aussi tu dois
avoir plein d'amis des mecs et des
filles est souvent ya des nanas que tu
préfères à d'autres une nana avec qui tu
aimerais bien aller un peu plus loin
seulement le problème c'est qu'il est
super dur de draguer sur snapshot est de
savoir si elle est intéressée
tu peux drague ouvertement mais curistes
de vraiment passer pour un blaireau
parce que si tu y vas caches tu peux
griller
il peut le montrer à d'autres elle fait
une capture d'écran et toi tu as l'air
d'un con snapshot comme tous les réseaux
sociaux ont leurs codes
il ya des petits signes qui ne trompent
pas qui te permettra de savoir si alain
actu vise elle est intéressée ou pas et
ses petits conseils je vais te donner
pourquoi parce que je suis sympa et
après on n'est pas tout d'abord cette
invite à me rejoindre dans ce match at
garde je te mets le snap todd je te mets
mon nom me cheuvreux tout attaché avec
trois r tu viens tu me rejoins et moi tu
verras je te donnerai pas mais je
partage des choses quand même qu'ils
sont sympas bon ceci étant dit voilà
comment il faut faire
il ya en tout neuf signe pour savoir si
nana est intéressé par toi / snapshots
et pas des signes qui pris
individuellement un par un vous
permettre de savoir c'est un hyper
intéressé par contre tu les prends tous
ça donnera une analyse complexe
permettra de savoir si vraiment elle est
intéressée ou si elle ne l'est pas le
tout premier c'est de savoir ce qui a
loupé et cela rapidement
si dès que tu lui envoies un snap je te
parle pas de story je te parle de snap
c'est dès que tu lui envoies un snap
elles ouvrent tout de suite ou dans les
minutes qui suivent ça veut dire qu'elle
est intéressée plus plus plus plus plus
et ça pour tout et cela alors tu auras
voit pas 15 me par jour mais tu envoies
quelques snap et tu verras ciel les
ouvre très rapidement ça veut dire
qu'elle est intéressée le deuxième point
c'est de savoir combien que vous envoyez
des sna par jour si tu envoies intenable
qu'elle ouvre que tu as eu de réponse
c'est banal n'y a pas grand chose mais à
partir de trois snap
tu peux être sûr qu'il ya de l'intérêt
si tu lui envoies un snap et qu'elle te
répond elle manifeste de l'intérêt c'est
clair au numéro 3 il faut savoir quel
type de snap sait si c'est un message
banal qui n'a aucun intérêt
bon on est dans le consensuel ce qu'on
envoie ses potes des pelles dans la
fredzone ya ce moment là il n'y a rien à
faire
par contre si les messages sont un peu
plus personnelle qu'ont les dents le
rigolo mais qu'on me nord dès qu'on
cherche un petit peu at séduire là tu
peux être sûr qu'elle est intéressé il
ya quelques signes qui permettent de
savoir si une femme et intérêts
et parfois déjà savoir si elle commence
un peu à minauder et lada qui me donne
c'est pénible mais par contre c'est un
bon indicateur
si elle fait ça vous sa belle tu peux
être sûr qu'elle est intéressée il ya
aussi un truc qui marche bien c'est les
cheveux elle se touche les cheveux alors
sur une vidéo sera plus évident tu vois
si elle se prend en photo genre on en
touchant les cheveux mais sur une vidéo
ça peut franchement marché et ça c'est
un point important
pareil si elle fait une petit mot avec
ses lèvres sam ont toujours un intérêt 1
ça veut dire je te fais un bisou
on les danses qu'au delà après c'est du
langage corporel il faut qu'ils sachent
décoder un petit peu que tu sache lire
entre les lignes
ça serait trop facile c est en voyant
broker remarque que je t'aime ou un
broker marqué j'ai envie de toi là a
forcément c'est open
tu sais qu'il peut y aller les choses
sont claires en règle générale
aucune fille de ses seins en règle
générale il y en a quelques-unes mais la
plupart du temps il faut savoir lire
entre les lignes
et sache que pour une fille c'est
évident si elle te fait une moue ça veut
dire qu'elles ont envie de te faire un
bisou ou pas compliqué les filles le
quatrième point c'est le message le
message en lui même est ce que c'est un
message personnalisé
est-ce qu'elle va prendre du temps est
ce qu'elle va faire des petits dessins
est-ce qu'elle va te rajouter du texte
du texte que pour toi un peu d'intimité
que vous ayez l'un avec l'autre
alors forcément au début ça va être côté
un petit peu abîmés ya toujours une
touche de séduction donc analyse bien le
message on analyse bien tout ce qu'elle
te mets dedans et tu verras c'est écrire
des choses avec son doigt qui est un
message qui est vraiment personnalisé ça
veut dire qu'elle peut vraiment
s'adresser et de faire passer un message
et c'est là dessus que tu verra s'il ya
un intérêt le cinquième point il un peu
plus vicelard mais il faut savoir si
elle regarde ta story c'est hyper simple
si elle regarde pas story ça veut dire
qu'elle est intéressée qu'elle te suit
activement si déjà vous vous envoyer des
messages régulièrement et qu'en plus de
ça elle regarde ta story qu'elle regarde
tout ce que tu publies là elle est
intéressée pour savoir c'est hyper
simple tu vas nota story de cliquer
dessus et tuba l'oeil du bas vers le
haut et tu vas avoir exactement le
nombre de personnes qui ont validé story
et quels sont ces personnes ma story
aujourd'hui moi c'est de la maison de
retraite ce fait beaucoup moins sexy le
tube à l'oeil du bas vers le haut et là
tu as la liste et le nombre de personnes
qui ont regardé
tu sais vraiment donc si elle te
regardes tu le sauras septième point est
ce qu'elle a fait une capture d'écran du
notte photo tu lui envoie une photo un
peu charmeur un peu beau gosse n'en fait
pas trop tard rapidement l'air d'un
blaireau mais si tu m'envoies du trou
dans lequel tu es à ton avantage est
qu'elle fait une capture d'écran ça veut
dire qu'elle te kiffe pourquoi est-ce
qu'elle s'embêterait avoir une photo de
toi dans son téléphone c'est pas contre
garder ou pour le montrer à ses copines
ça marche comme ça les filles elles ont
toujours besoin de l'aval de leurs amis
comment te trouvais ce qu'il est bien
moi il plaît tu en penses quoi
huitième point c'est la qualité le sens
là tout se recoupe mais est-ce qu'elle a
pris du temps à faire une belle photo à
t'envoyer un vrai message à passer du
temps pour te séduire
est-ce qu'elle s'est mise en scène si
elle s'est juste pris en photo la tête
en farine et le matin ou à la limite
avec dalé de putois relate uféras
franchement qu'elle cherche pas de
séduire
si par contre elle et à son avantage
dans son livre alors là c'est jackpot si
elle se prend en photo dans le genre et
il manque plus que toi et aux banques
aux mecs
tous ces codes il faut les connaître le
neuvième point est un petit peu en
dehors de snapshot
quel comportement elle avec toit en dur
de snapshot commente par le lui dis lui
tiens t'as vu sur snapshot jetant voyait
sa droite à photo est super et vous
parler un peu de snapshot et vous parler
un peu de la régularité
tu lui en parle tout est une chèque tu
vois sur le nombre de messages que vous
envoyez par jour sur ce que vous en
voyez et tu vois comment il répond cela
les gêne et si l intéressé s'il ya une
ouverture si elle s'attaque ouvertement
ça c'est vraiment des points importants
tu regardes ses neuf points sur snapshot
et après tu sors de snapshot et tu y vas
en vrai parce que c'est bien beau tout
ça tu vas quand même pas aller rouler
des pelles à ton écran ça n'a aucun sens
c'est qu'elle conseille donc permettre
de pouvoir décoder décoder ce que disent
les fans sait très bien qu'en règle
générale les femmes et les hommes
on fonctionne pas du tout pareil elle
fonctionne en langage cacher et si tu
arrives toi à décoder et à lire entre
les lignes
tu ne pourra que savoir si elle est
intéressée parce que si ça se trouve il
ya des nanas qui sont intéressés par toi
mais comme tu sais pas lire entre les
lignes et que tu parles pas le langage
des femmes et battant c'est absolument
rien du tout et être passé à côté de
certaines nana qui te plaisais donc tu
fais attention à ça tu regardes un petit
peu tu vois les signes tu voyais cette
ombre des messages réguliers
elle répond à tous tes messages 6 et
personnalisés quelle attitude est là
est-ce qu'elle a des attitudes qui est
particulière envers toi et envers les
autres potes c'est différent se
permettra aussi d'analyser et de voir si
elle est intéressée par toi on regarde
ça plus en détails et n'hésite pas à me
dire c'est à repérer des petits points
qui pouvaient accrocher
si si mes conseils ont marché ou pas et
si tu as réussi à choper grâce à ça si
sa taille des tumeurs petites pousses du
ta bonne je te ferai d'autres contenus
comme ça le but de la chaîne c'est aussi
aider ta portée des bons conseils
apportés des tuyaux pour t'aider dans ta
ville mecque et sache que c'est pas
toujours facile
si moi j'avais j'attends un conseil et
non plus jeunes sa mort est largement
est grandement facilité la vie et au
fait tu as regardé cette vidéo la la
cette vidéo là est-ce que tu la regardes
et franchement elle est sympa et
n'oublie pas pour ta bonne et c'est
juste en dessous tu ta bonne à bientôt
ciao